trying to see if I should adjust my diet. I have put on 30 pounds in the last eight months.
I haven't changed my diet. Whole food, no sugar, no dairy. Also, I know gluten,
or my workouts, four to five times a week. I know my four bones are low. And you said that
is good due to having breast cancer, but should I do hormone replacement or adjust my diet suggestions?
Should I go do fasting? I did start the heart and soil supplement. I emailed you about maybe
see if this helps. Yeah, so this is where, you know, you go, okay, what am I doing wrong?
I put on 30 pounds in the last eight months. I haven't changed a thing. This is where is,
you know, measure read. I don't remember Jessica if we did a cortisol panel on you or not.
That's where, you know, looking at that might be the right thing to look at for you and see how
we can get that cortisol levels down. Maybe do it going with adaptogenic herbs or something like that.
Very unique. I don't, uh, don't without getting very specific with you.